[موسيقى]
عاده اذا بدنا نحكي ايش المشاكل اللي ممكن
يتعرض لها الشخص المشهور اعاده ممكن يصابه
بالاكتئاب جدا يعني
بين المشاهير القلق التوتر اضطرابات النوم
اضطرابات الاكل
كتير
بنفس الطريقه او نفس القوه ونفس القدره
امام الجمهور
اول شيء بنحكي انه انت عادهم عن مراقبه
السوشل ميديا كثير بساعدهم على الناس
عددهن بتعلق من خلف الشاشات
وبتنطق وممكن تبيح لنفسها لانها تحكي
بحياه الفنانه الخاصه وتصير هيك
زي ما بنحكي مشاعر وبتصير الناس بتحلل
فيهم
وهذا الموضوع
الاجتماعي يعني اكيد الموضوع مو سهل
نهائيا انت عادهم عن السوشيال ميديا
على صحه النفسيه وكل فنان كل شخص او كل
مشهور في له الطريقه الخاصه له اللي ممكن
انه المعالج نفسه او الطبيب النفسي تبعاو
يحاول يساعده فيها دائما عم ننسى لانه ايش
رايكم وضع الفنانه شيرين وايش ممكن تضيفوا
او ايش ممكن يتحلل
بالذات هاي النقطه هي اللي اصلا احنا
بنحكي ان هي بتاثر سلبا بحاله الفنان
النفسيه او حاله المشهور لانه همم شعورنا
من احنا او او السباحه بدي احكي بدي احكي
هيك السباحه ان الواحد
بتفسير اشياء احنا شايفينها بس من بعيد
اصلا من الاشياء اللي بتاثر سلبي على
نفسيتك الفنانه
[موسيقى]
تخيل الاثار النفسيه للفنان لما هي تطلع
عن المكان اللي فيها هلا موجوده فيها
وبتشوف التحليلات تبعت البشر
[موسيقى]